[موسيقى]
ذلك المكان لو اخذتها الكاميرا لكم ستكون
واضحه هذه الزخاير يمكن ان تنفجر في اي
لحظه بفعل درجات الحراره المرتفعه هذه
الايام فضلا عن اي حركه
في هذه الزغاير عن طريقه التدحرج او عن
طريق ان تضعها اقدام الماره او اطارات
السيارات التي تعبر من هذا المكان يبدو
واضحا ان هذه
المتفجرات تحتاج الى
مختصين حتى يمكن
التقاطها من هنا
وبحيث يمكن ازاله الخطر من هذا المكان
يبدو واضحا اثار الانفجار في البنايات
بحيث بسبب الانفجارات التي
تسببت فيها هذه الذخائر مما الحقت اضرار
بالغه بالبنيات
هذه البنايات هي
السكن لضباط الشرطه ايضا يبدو واضحا وجليا
الاضرار التي لحقت بواجهه السوق المركزي
وهو سوق رئيسي في المنطقه هذه المعركه
تبدو اثارها هجريه
وتعب من ابرز
المعارك واعنفها في هذه المنطقه
يبدو الوضع هنا يحتاج الى تدخل السلطات
بشكل عاجل حتى يمكن التقاط وتفكيك هذه
المتفجرات والذخائر التي تبدو متنازله
بشكل عشوائي في ظل استمرار حركه السير في
هذا المكان الذي شهد في صول معركه حاميه
بين القوتين المتحاربتين منذ الخامس عشر
من هذا الشهر